[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen
i'm malcolm rivkind i have been invited
to take
the session that we're about to begin uh
perhaps i can just begin if i may
just by explaining as far as i have a
competence
to speak on the subject before us what
that competence is
i served for a total of six years in the
british foreign office as minister of
state and then as foreign secretary
and was also defense secretary this was
during the governments of
margaret thatcher and john major and in
the early session as a junior minister
as minister of state
i was responsible under the prime
minister and the foreign secretary
for our relations with the soviet union
and was involved in
uh margaret thatcher's meeting with mr
gorbachev the famous meeting
when she said he is a man with whom we
can do
business uh so i was able to see it
firsthand
uh the chemistry of that meeting and
what it then led to
and the subject is the uh is the
end of history what happened in 1989
and in the immediate period there after
and that phrase the end of history
it wasn't just invented it was a an
american academic
professor fukuyama who suggested that so
crucial
were the events of those years that it
really was the end of history because it
was a triumph
of the west the triumph of democracy and
of the values that we have
and the issue that we are discussing
this morning and which others have
discussed
is whether that was a wise thing for him
to say
or whether the events that we have seen
in the last 20 to 30 years uh suggests
not that it wasn't important
um but that uh in some respects we're
going back or have gone back
to the bad old days so i begin by
just emphasizing the significance of
what happened in 1989
and his extraordinary coincidence that
that of course was a hundred years
after the fall of the bastille which
began the french revolution
so in 1989 was not one event it was
actually
three historic events all connected with
each other
but all nevertheless distinct in a way
that i will explain very briefly
first of all it was the end of the cold
war and the cold war was that
geopolitical struggle between the soviet
union
and the west particularly the united
states and it could at any stage have
led from a cold war to a hot war
a third world war and if it had done of
course it would have had the added
horror
of nuclear weapons and it would have
been the possibility of a nuclear
exchange which could have
literally destroyed all human life and
the planet which we are part
so the cold war came to an end
and whatever problems we have with mr
putin today and we have serious problems
they are not of the same order because
uh
in the case of the soviet union it was
at one period the military equal
of the united states which russia
certainly is not it was economically
strong at one stage which russia is
not and of course it had global
aspirations whereas mr putin
is more of an opportunist uh rather than
someone seeking to dominate
the world so the end of the cold war
was the first dramatic change and of
course the cold war immediately followed
the second world war
and therefore europe was beginning to
get back to some degree of normality
so i said there were three things that
happened that was the first
the second simultaneously but in a
different way in terms of the detail
was it was the great end of the
ideological struggle
between communism and capitalism between
communism and market economics
because there is no communist society
today with a mild exception of north
korea but even that
is basically a totalitarian despotism
china is still run by a communist party
as
is vietnam and cuba but their societies
are not communist
in any marxist leninist sense in the
case of china you essentially
have state capitalism and why did
communism collapse why did it fail
essentially because it couldn't deliver
economically
what mr gorbachev when he came to
britain
most noted was how when he was shown a
supermarket
it wasn't a supermarket for the
privileged for the members of the
political elite
it had a marvelous extraordinary display
of choice and this was
for ordinary members of the public
everyone was able to do their shopping
in that way and that was just one
example
of the failure of communism somebody had
remarked
that communism only worked either in
heaven
where they did not need it or in hell
where they had it
already that might have been a bit
unkind but it summed up
uh what could be described so communism
failed as a system and of course what
you saw after the
1989 was not just introduction of
capitalism and market economics
throughout eastern europe and poland and
hungary
czech republic the baltic states but
even russia itself
uh through the oligarchs it's not the
kind of capitalism
that we have in britain but it
nevertheless is closer to capitalism
than it ever was to socialism or
communism and that is something
irreversible
so that's the second big change that
happened at that time
first the end of the cold war the second
uh the
collapse of communism as an alternative
global ideology and it was global
because it had many adherents in other
parts of the world and
for many years during the cold war the
french and italian communist parties
were the largest political parties in
france in
italy although they never got far now
i come to the third and it's the third
big change
that is explains a lot of the problems
we are living with
at the moment because the third dramatic
change
the one that was least predicted even in
the timescale we're talking about was
the collapse of
europe's last empire the russian
empire the british empire had gone
gradually over the years has had the
french
the spanish the portuguese the belgian
the dutch and so forth all had
disappeared
the russian empire was the last to go
and i'm not just talking about the end
of the warsaw pact and
countries like poland and hungary and so
forth are becoming free again and
becoming
essentially central europe i'm actually
talking about the implosion
of the soviet union itself the state
called the soviet union previously
russia
disintegrated into 15 or 16 separate
independent countries russia was the
largest
ukraine was the second largest and then
you have the baltic states
states of the caucasus georgia armenia
azerbaijan
the central asian states kazakhstan
uzbekistan several others
and so forth so this was something
totally
uh unexpected even to the russians
themselves
but it happened and of course the
consequence of that
is that if for example physical war were
ever to begin
between russia and the west it would not
begin
in the center of germany where it would
have been up till 1989 with
half of berlin controlled ultimately by
the soviet union
russia's borders are now very very far
to the east
they would have to go through belarus
they'd have to go through the baltic
states
or ukraine before they even got to
poland and still
some way so from a conventional point of
view
russia no longer can be seen as a threat
in the way that the soviet union was
now mr putin's statement the most
important statement i think he's made
was before he even became president
of russia when he said that the greatest
geopolitical disaster of his lifetime
was the collapse
of the soviet uh state because he didn't
mean communism he meant the russian
empire
and because right from today's borders
of
russia you have to go back to peter the
great in the 17th century
um towards the end of the 17th century
when our borders
were as far from the rest of europe as
they are
today and that's why he is determined
to uh limit the independence of ukraine
if possible to reabsorb them into the
russian embrace
while he tries to destabilize the baltic
states and so forth
so you had these three massive changes
and there's no doubt
that the immediate effect of that in the
early 1990s
was that communism had disappeared
the soviet union was no longer a threat
and needed its leaders gorbachev and
then yeltsin
wanted to become closer to the west and
looked at one stage as if that could
lead
to russia as well as eastern europe
adopting a parliamentary system the rule
of law
becoming more integrated into the
european family
of nations so that you know these were
pretty impressive things
but what we have saw thereafter uh and
it didn't take long for it to begin to
happen you started off with the united
states
becoming the sole superpower indeed so
powerful was america that it wasn't as a
superpower it was a super duper bar
the only one we actually had far more
powerful than
russia now was china was no longer it
was not yet
uh as powerful as it is today and so
that looked as if the united states
really was a pax americana that would
determine the fortunes of the world
but that only lasted a few years i began
by quoting professor fukuyama who said
it was the end
of history that was rather optimistic
i believe in an alternative phrase as
one door closes
another slams in your face because it
didn't take long
for things to begin happening in europe
that were very very unpleasant
very very disagreeable which we thought
might have gone forever
we got the return of xenophobic
nationalism
particularly for example in the balkans
where yugoslavia
has collapsed disintegrated into
half a dozen separate states and the
most serious consequence was the bosnian
effectively civil war when bosnian serbs
bosnian kurtz bosnian muslims
all fought each other we had ethnic
cleansing for several years
and that was something that europe
thought would never occur ending with
the
ghastliness of the srebrenica massacre
but it wasn't just in yugoslavia
because also within russia itself to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you